The secretary of state is Mike Pompeo.
And Mike Pompeo yesterday said during a brief
press availability that once every legal vote
is counted, there will be a smooth transition
into a second Trump administration.
So he is continuing to appear to reject the
fact that Democratic challenger Joe Biden
is now the president elect of the United States
and has defeated Donald Trump.
This is now going very high.
This is not Republican senators being quiet.
This is the secretary of state, a top administration
official, refusing to accept the results.
And, of course, why wouldn't he?
The top administration official, Donald Trump,
continues to say he won Pennsylvania and Nevada
and Wisconsin and Georgia and other states.
Let's take a look at the video of Mike Pompeo.
Is the State Department currently preparing
to engage with the Biden transition team?
And if not, at what point does a delay hamper
a smooth transition or pose a risk to national
security?
There will be a smooth transition to a second
Trump administration.
All right.
We're ready.
The world is watching what's taking place.
We're going to count all the votes when the
process is complete.
They'll be electors selected.
There's a process.
The Constitution lays it out pretty clearly.
The world should have every confidence that
the transition necessary to make sure that
the State Department is functional today,
successful today, and successful with a president
who's in office on January 20th.
A minute afternoon will also be a success.
So this is actually starting to sound mildly
seditious, which is about right for this administration.
This is actually terrifying, not because it
might actually prevent Joe Biden from becoming
president, but because it shows the level
of disconnect from reality that more than
just Donald Trump have.
Or alternatively, the other explanation for
why Mike Pompeo is doing this would be Pompeo
knows that Trump lost, but he's being bullied
into repeating this nonsense, which is arguably
just as bad.
Now, consider that Mike Pompeo has a lot of
official travel coming up in the next few
weeks.
Mike Pompeo is supposed to go to France, Turkey,
Georgia, Israel, Qatar, the UAE, Saudi Arabia.
The leaders of some of those countries that
will be visited by Mike Pompeo in the coming
weeks have already.
Adulated Joe Biden, Israel is an example,
France is an example, the others I'm less
sure about.
What is Pompeo say to them when he gets there?
We're not leaving.
Don't worry.
We're getting another term.
You're going to be working with a second Trump
administration and not a Biden administration,
even though you've already congratulated Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris.
How is that going to work?
And from Mike Pompeo, his answer yesterday,
this is still shaping up to be a very long
couple of months and also a very humiliating
couple of months for the Trump administration.
And we've talked for years now about the normalization
of really crazy things under the Trump administration.
Comments like these from Mike Pompeo.
These are unprecedented by state officials
in situations like this.
It is not common that in the United States,
after an election is done, after the votes
are in showing that there is an irreversible
victory by one candidate after that individual
has started, an office of the president elect
has started a transition for a secretary of
state to still be denying that that is what
has taken place.
This is unprecedented and we should not allow
it to be normalized.
First, they refuse to assist in transition
planning.
Now they're suggesting there's no need for
transition planning because Trump is going
to get himself a second term.
Now, I want to ask Trump a question and I
worry.
I know the answer.
Where is the line?
When will the disdain for democracy and the
continued authoritarianism be too much even
for Trump ists?
I don't know that I need to ask because recent
polling shows that most Republicans now believe
Donald Trump that the election was stolen
by Joe Biden.
It's actually that bad.
And why would we think there is a line they've
spent the last four years defending everything
Donald Trump has said and done, no matter
how outrageous, no matter how dystopian or
authoritarian, including suggesting, as Donald
Trump did, that he could murder someone on
Fifth Avenue without any political repercussions.
Why would we believe there is any line Trump
could cross?
There isn't.
And this is actually Donald Trump's best chance
at staying in office.
The only thing that if you force me to come
up with that, I find the slightest bit interesting
about this entire disaster is the idea that
if Donald Trump really is going to try to
just stay, his removal from the Oval Office
on January 20th is going to be absolutely
riveting and rewarding to see, but it will
greatly damage and embarrass the country if
it were come to that, if it were to come to
that.
So as entertaining as it would be, as much
as I would relish seeing Donald Trump being
removed, I actually hope it doesn't happen
because it would be really bad for the country.
The American people have spoken.
It's time to go, guys.
I get it.
It's a thin margin.
Couple of hundred thousand votes in four states,
seven thousand votes in two states.
But Trump only won in twenty sixteen because
of 77000 votes in three states.
It was close then as well.
If it were popular vote, Hillary would have
easily won in 2016 by popular vote.
Joe Biden won even more easily in twenty twenty.
But it's time to go.
You're embarrassing yourselves.
This was a fair and rightful process where
people chose their leaders.
They are not just trampling on the process,
they're ridiculing the process and in doing
so, ridiculing the United States of America,
which deserves some ridicule because the country
did elect Donald Trump in 2016.
They claim to be for law and order.
They claim to be for the Constitution.
They're certainly not acting like it.
And we're going to have continued coverage
of this on our Instagram page.
Find us at The David Pakman Show on Instagram